when you look at the piggy bank chart
what does that say about pending dis
inflation and deflation in the world
well the China piggy bank chart is
largely a result of the fact that people
know the RMB has to go down as well as
go up so you had a massive rebalancing
of Chinese companies liabilities they
used to borrow in dollars in by RMB
because it was a one web set and that
boosted foreign exchange reserves once
they realized the RMB had to decline a
bit they reversed that so you had a big
drop in Chinese companies dollar debts
and a corresponding drop in Chinese
reserves
it simply rebalance into the corporate
sector Bank for two national settlements
cover that pretty thoroughly
it doesn't really reflect Chinese
economic confidence as much as algae the
reality David and you were way out front
in this is the decline in aggregate
trade I said you and Carl Weinberg we're
quarters ahead of everybody else how
urgent is the decline in world trade
well this is as you indicate this is the
elephant in the parlor because with
world trade actually negative
year-on-year with this as of the second
quarter we're at the point we're very
close to global recession that makes
China's problems much more difficult
than they ought to be China's trying to
obviously move from a polluting factory
based old economy to a more high-tech
new economy and that's made it much more
difficult by the fact that their export
sector is in very poor shape China
however is doing reasonably well I keep
reading Bloomberg stories which talk
about a Chinese financial crisis I don't
see it that way
you have state-owned banks that owe
money to the state itself so it's the
state that owes money to itself it's
much more a matter of getting labor out
of the old industries and inch new jobs
moved retrained within documents that's
a ten year process and it's even
steadily but slowly but David how do you
see so we saw some some figures and
actually we've also written to stick up
for my team we've also written a lot of
stories saying that China stabilizing
but today we have
chyna credit growth slowed to two year
low on this debt curb concern again how
are the Chinese authorities seeing this
are they suggesting that we're concerned
that they're concerned about swelling
financial risks from as an economist I
would argue China's real rates are too
high and they should cut rates but the
Chinese Authority is judging from all
the recent pronouncements we've had from
the Chinese press are saying the exact
opposite they want to keep real rates
high and that's because they want to
keep the feet to the fire of the old
industries they want to force reforms
that want to force a shift out of
employment in the old smokestack
industries into newer industries I think
it's mainly a political gesture on the
part of the Chinese authorities and
they're not giving the old industries
any breathing room anyway to the labor
force but this seems like a policy
priority right is that fair if they have
growth that's stabilized and again it
may change very quickly
if they fall below six and a half
percent growth but if growth is
stabilizing they want to focus on
curbing financial risk absolutely that
well financial risk is really political
risk the issue is how much rope do you
give the old industries by continuing to
finance them you know they're they're
not going to pay a pair in any case but
that's just a liability of the state to
itself politically they have to worry
about unemployment in one hand in
certain regions in the aggregate they
don't have an unemployment problem so as
long as growth as you indicate stays in
the six percent range they'll keep
credit I mean if they fall below it
they're going to lean in the other
direction and give some rope